this is a production of cornell
university
um this is the third installment of our
erp webinar series we've done
a webinar on irrigation management with
rick slattery former superintendent uh
learned a lot from his uh you know long
career in turf we did a nutrient
management webinar where i talked about
a bunch of bmps in our project um there
and then today we're going to have frank
rossi talk about pest management bmp so
talking about
responsible chemical use and
all the practices associated with that
so uh with that frank i'll turn it over
to you
thank you carl um
and welcome everyone uh whether watching
live or uh recorded um
i have to say that this project with my
colleagues
um here at cornell carl and rick
slattery retired from the locust hill
country club
and our colleagues at the pollution
prevention institute gene park
um mia
selina
ken
all the people all the interns that have
worked with us a big shout out to
everybody that's really helped bring
this together i i can say it's really a
a wonderful model to consider
uh serving the citizens of the state of
new york with this particular form of
land use and the way we'd like to have
people do it all right let me see if i
get my slides advanced here well just
i'll embarrass my colleagues here they
are rick rick in in uh reese in younger
days and and carl this past weekend uh
bringing home the mid am
the new york state mid-am championship
so we are steeped in golf i've been
working on golf courses for 40 years
rick about 50
uh and carl's been playing golf since
high school so he's been at it quite a
bit himself lots of experience here and
that's been really important as we
reflect on
previous surveys that may have been done
uh
of the golf industry in this space uh
but but also
maybe looking at things in a more
comprehensive way rick
very
business-minded economic minded about
being efficient
on the golf course and and carl really
from the front of the house perspective
and the golfer experience perspective i
think we really got a really important
team here we can continue to do uh
really good work as long as i can put up
with rick and his stinking red sox
nevertheless this is really all built up
around the codifying of these
environmental standards uh led by ken
benoit and many in the new york golf
course foundation years ago
we wrote these things and
i think ultimately we always believed
that we needed education and support to
get them adopted and i think uh ken and
the years we spent getting this going
has really helped adoption
but i think the project we're talking
about here
uh centered in a section of the state in
western new york very different than the
downstate uh emphasis that the bmps
initially started with
we wanted to explore the 200 or some odd
golf courses that were available to us
in the western part of new york state
hit western central finger lakes
depending on how you like to classify it
and essentially for those of you who
haven't joined us before
you know we wanted to make sure we knew
what the bmps were what were the things
that would indicate the important bmps
and then
ask people are they implementing those
bmps now once we get the data back from
that then we're in the phase right now
where we're encouraging adoption we're
putting out resources we're holding
webinars uh developing publications and
then uh in in a month in months a year
from now we'll then say hey did what we
do
improve the adoption of these practices
that essentially the law doesn't make
you do right we're looking at will will
our industry adopt some of these things
voluntarily so we went around and asked
a bunch of questions uh many of you
again may have seen this here's some of
the fertilizer and pesticide questions
and
when we went out and got our surveys and
did this work carl and rick especially
went around uh we were doing it remotely
during the pandemic and then later on
got some very interesting answers that
at least from the pest perspective i'll
talk a little bit about today
so as carl mentioned we've already done
the water and nutrient webinars this is
the pest webinar we'll have one more on
pollution that'll be very much focused
on wash pad uh and point source issues
but the focus for my time today is with
you on pests now
a lot of things have happened since we
started this project uh 18 months ago
and one of the great things is now we
have this wonderful web-based resource
housed at rit and the galasano center
for sustainability uh through the new
york state pollution prevention
institute we've got a web pages on golf
course sustainability that lists all the
resources that we've been
able to
produce so far
videos publications uh none more
important than this big old poster you
see here to the right so as i mentioned
earlier we're in the encourage adoption
are you doing this
how do we help you improve these things
what did our survey say you weren't
doing well that we could help you with
and so obviously the poster uh has been
a big part of this we're going to
actually make some bigger ones starting
to see them up in golf course shops
trying to get this in the uh culture of
our industry uh we've been out doing a
little bit of field days we're hoping to
do more
as the pandemic slows and we're able to
get back out
and then of course we're also doing some
direct assistance projects and brief
assistance projects where we're working
directly with a client uh helping them
adopt it and then hopefully writing it
up and getting it out to everyone else
now of course you know me i don't shut
up we got all kinds of webinars we had a
uh
tip of the day i think we did it 10
weeks in a row this past spring where we
were highlighting a particular uh bmp
throughout the season throughout the
spring so you obviously can go back and
see more about that we're gonna revisit
that and so just for today
let's get back to what my job is for
today
my job for today is to talk a little bit
about this one section of the um
indicator survey that we want to uh
elaborate a little bit more on all right
um of the many brilliant things my
colleague carl has uh suggested over the
years of working together i would have
to rank this among the top um being able
to look at how you're doing based on
good better best right you know there's
this little saying never let it rest
until you're good is better and you're
better is best right but you know so
best management practices right what
we're trying to say is par
might be best in some case might be the
best you can do
right but there are birdies and eagles
out there that we can tell you science
is saying this is a a bad the best
approach and if we want to do best
management practices for now i'm willing
to say it's the best you can do but as
we inform and learn more about this uh
especially with the way we're looking at
it as an operation you know rick from a
real economic perspective environmental
perspective call call from the golf and
environmental perspective and me from
you know
sort of a little bit about everything so
um again here is the pest section and
there were three pars
three birdies and two eagles that were
listed in this path section where we say
well you know you should be doing these
things right making par well it'd be
really great if you were doing these
birdies and boy these eagles are really
you know where we want you to be and
also you'll see there's a pro tip there
the questions from the pesticide section
essentially broke down uh to these five
that we'll focus on a little bit for
today
one is we ask do you apply the majority
of your pesticides does not apply
the majority of the pesticides
preventatively right so most people are
applying them preventatively uh about
half and half spot treating
three quarters are maintaining a 25 foot
chemical free buffer we'll get into this
a little bit more and then there's
maintaining a longer vegetation area
around there and a documented spill
control program so you can see some are
more adopted than others based on our
survey results with the way we ask the
questions now
unfortunately i'm going to take a little
bit of a left turn here uh and start
with the pro tip not par birdie eagle
and the pro tip here really gets to how
do you set up a situation where your
grasses can be successful so they don't
need chemical pesticides uh to be
applied and rick's uh saying here is you
know trees don't thrive in the prairies
nor grass in the forest
you've got to have good growing
conditions so
a pro tip of course is going to pay
attention to the growing environment in
particular
tree shade the impacts that it has now
again rick being the uh the the macgyver
of the group uh found himself an app and
there probably are a few out there many
of you may know about this maybe you
don't there are apps you can get on your
phone that you just hold it up in the
sky and it gives you a
view of where the sun is going to be
it gives you the opportunity to
communicate to your members to your
golfers
to your crew
you know where the trees are impacting
light penetration now from a broader
perspective number of years ago uh james
francis moore jim moore the old usga
agronomist based in texas used to come
up here and
with that southern drawl and talk about
the grading system they used to have for
greens and i always liked it as a way of
really evaluating your site now it could
be a green could be a fairway could be a
tea there might be different components
to this i'd encourage you to look this
up uh this particular article in one of
the older usga green section records and
in that article
jim actually says okay if you get uh you
know less than four to six hours
if you're at four to six hours of direct
sunlight you're getting a c
so that's not a good growing condition
right so you'll want to use some of
these metrics in communicating how
you're gonna maybe have to adapt the
growing environment now of course trees
also
affect air movement and so
um now you can go to the trouble of
putting fans in but i would say maybe
some thinning of the canopy could go a
long way to
improving the growing conditions there
now
another pro tip that's actually
associated with what my colleague rick
slattery talked about earlier in the
webinar series about water is that
there's no strength without stress
right if you can stress your turf at the
right times where it can tolerate that
stress it will become stronger for the
future now if you really want to hear
about this many years ago i had this
chat with rick on my podcast on turfnet
radio where we talked a little bit about
his philosophy regarding the way he
approached uh managing the golf course
out there but this picture really
typifies a lot of what i believe you'll
hear in that podcast and what we're
trying to promote with this pro tip so
here you have at the bottom the bottom
white arrow is annual bluegrass
population that's being decimated by
dollar spot right and right above it you
see bent grass above in the top white
arrow the bent grass spreading and
thriving right without spraying so you
give a little bit of stress now this
works also been done uh at rutgers
looking at annual bluegrass weevil
as a way of taking out annual bluegrass
some people have talked about using
summer patch as a way of taking out
annual bluegrass letting some of these
things that you would normally have to
spray for
that inherently aren't a problem on
particular grasses in this case creeping
bank grass and let that do the work for
you in shifting the competition making
the stress uh take out the weaker
species so it's a pro tip of you know
getting yourself more competitive by
having a good site it's a pro tip on
letting your turf be a little bit
stressed because it will likely be more
resilient later on and i'll remind you
as rick did in this slide this
particular damaged area represents a
really small section of this particular
tea
on the golf course and so will you
actually spray
all your teas or even this tea just
because the back where it's a tight turn
is having a little trouble right so
again a little bit of stress
not triggering an overall pesticide use
is certainly one way of reducing
pesticide use now i'll go a little bit
further with some uh slide that many of
you might have seen me speak before have
seen me talk about in my work at the
vineyard golf club with jeff carlson and
now kevin banks
many years early on in the study of of
the in the development of this organic
golf course that doesn't use synthetic
fungicides
um they were having grub problems and
ever invariably they would have to
re-sod some tea areas so what you're
looking at here is some sod that's been
damaged that was laid in june of 07 and
photographed in july of 08.
and if you can see the damage from
dollar spot that is not occurring on the
original l93 that was seeded in august
of one that's become more resistant over
time that the diseases have selected for
the strongest varieties out there right
so they don't have synthetic fungicides
and likely the sod that came from the
mainland had synthetic fungicides on it
so the second year
when the fungicides weren't used all you
have remaining here are those
parent types or those resistant types
that exist in the bent grass sod and
eventually over time you'll develop a
population of plants that are highly
resistant to particular diseases so
again you can only see this if you let
some stress happen now just a point of
order here allowing your golf course to
look like that sod on the left probably
isn't the best idea unless like the
vineyard club you're forced to do so
obviously communicating this and doing
it strategically throughout the golf
course is going to be really critical to
ensure ensuring you know the overall
success of this practice
right so
again
another
uh
bmp from not the pest section but
relates directly to the pest section is
improving the competition and i
mentioned that earlier uh with getting a
good site and then it's allowing some
stress to come in right that gives you a
more competitive stand and now
what about actually using and
intentionally installing the latest
turfgrass varieties that for pesticides
have really been improved to be more
resistant now again we use this from a
water perspective thinking that you'd
plant you know varieties that would
require less water but you also see in
this birdie right maybe a step up where
you can reduce pesticides and
fertilizers now
the really beautiful thing i'll commend
you to hear is if you're on twitter or
social media or you read anything from
the usga and you search corning country
club or john hoyle h-o-y-l-e
john has embarked upon a multi-year plan
at corning country club to spray out the
heinz 57 mix of grasses in his fairways
that have caused him
nothing but trouble lots of spraying
lots of
inconsistent conditions and he embarked
upon a multiple year plan with the club
to spray out the existing grasses and
then
several fairways a year install the
latest bent grass varieties and again i
could probably talk and john has given
presentations on this but it's a real
good example of working with your club
to get varieties out there that might
help you with pesticide use so
how do what how do you sell this from a
pesticide perspective
i'm going to talk about predicting risk
and using models that tell us when
diseases are likely to occur we're going
to talk about that in a second but it's
in it's important here to understand
when the environment uh changes and
becomes conducive for a disease we can
measure how much pressure that's going
to be what the likelihood of you having
that disease is likely to be and we
would call that a threshold
and we would say well if you have a low
threshold you've got to spray sooner and
if you have a high threshold you can
wait to spray right it means the the
pressure that the grasses you have there
uh can tolerate that the pressure is
greater that the grasses you have there
might be able to tolerate so carl looked
at a bunch of data using the smith
kearns model one model that's used to
predict diseases
over a nine year one two three four five
six seven eight eight year period right
where you see every year there is an
increasing amount of dollar spot
pressure and then a decreasing amount of
dollar spot pressure so let's say
you had that heinz 57 mix that john had
out there a corny country club and he
would get dollar spot and i'm making
this up as a hypothetical but you know
the point i'm trying to make we
certainly have this at cornell
university fairways we have susceptible
varieties where when it gets to about 20
we're probably gonna get dollar spot we
better spray if i don't want a lot of
damage okay
once i put in a new variety like john's
doing
that have come from dollar spot
resistant material
now
if i use a model to spray
my threshold could go up to 40 to 50
percent
now look at the difference in the amount
of time i'd have to spray there would be
two years in a row here where i
literally wouldn't have to spray my
fairways at all
three years four years out of eight even
if you you know you pinched uh
2017 or 2016 you're seeing very little
periods of time
where you actually would need to spray
so again carlson did some economics here
looking at 250 an acre 25 acres of
fairways an old variety of six apps new
variety of three apps look at how much
money you basically save fifty percent
on just costs by putting in a new
variety every single year you're saving
that right and that's if you had to make
three apps what if you didn't have to
make any so again
having competitive grasses in there is a
birdie it is a birdie but it can result
in significant cost savings all right so
let's get into the actual bmps here uh
that we're going to want to cover uh
related to pesticide use
the first is a basic par welcome to the
buffer zone and again if you go back
into the bmp documents that have been
developed and available on the website
you'll see
these graphics about different ways of
approaching limited spray no spray
around a protected area right so we're
saying that a par is about a 25 foot
chemical free buffer now our survey said
70 of the golf courses are currently
starting to do this so this is a real uh
positive result so far of the things
that we're doing now the 2.0
from a par to a birdie now we're talking
about longer vegetation around water
bodies that even if you treat out here
in fairways and teas and playable rough
you've got an even longer buffer zone
that and also
that prevents pesticides and fertilizers
potentially from getting to that water
body but more so that you have these
wide areas right where you move the
maintenance from look at all the
trimming here on the right around the
body of water
and all the change this is at the
preserve at in in greenville south
carolina where uh adam charles has uh
and so much buffer area through that
golf course he estimated he he had
almost six to eight full-time people
that their entire seasonal job was to
keep that area clear from uh you know
maintained like it is on the right and
by doing that he was able to reallocate
some of that labor and that's a really
important component of these buffer
strips not just to prevent runoff from
getting in there not not just from
reducing the pesticide use in those
areas but also the labor associated with
maintaining these areas to the standards
on the right
okay
one of the things i love to do i get to
do in this project a lot is hang out
with rick slattery on tuesday mornings
and once we get through a little bit of
golf chatter and
giving each other a hard time about the
red sox and patriots and the yankees
one of the things he really beats the
drum about is
why do you run out there and do things
early in the spring in the northeast
when there really isn't much pressure
right there probably or you can wait
wait wait quite a long time until you
really need to start intervening on some
of these practices right and so if you
have the ability to avoid preventative
sprays right we had a really low
adoption a lot of people are
preventatively spraying now there's a
couple of things going on here if a lot
of our survey
the people that we surveyed were on what
we would call small operations
mom-and-pop operations right they're
just routinely treating their putting
surfaces because that's a very small
area and it's high value to them they're
not out on the golf course spraying
fairways rough far rough
right maybe a tea here there may be a
weed areas here or there but in general
you know many people were answering
preventatively from both the
private and the public sector uh because
the public sector even with low inputs
are still treating their greens
preventatively now one of the things i
want us to think about is is thinking
about um
how you use your pesticides on large
areas not necessarily your putting right
so if you're talking about three acres
of your putting greens right that's a
very different situation than 25 30
acres of fairway treatment for dollar
spot or anthracnose or something like
that right so one of the things we want
to
get everybody thinking about is if you
look at when you're likely to get a
disease whether it's in ithaca or on
long island
right from a dollar spot perspective
there's data to demonstrate most of the
time you probably don't have to start
treating until a little bit later on
now
at our forecast website at our forecast
website
we have an ability to look at various
intervals back and forward with a with
predicting what's going to happen
depending on your location so when you
look at the season-long dollar spot risk
estimates you can see here in may
there is very little need for dollar
spot but then look what starts to happen
we had a lot of dollar spot pressure uh
this year based on our forecast model
and i think our models indicating this
year there was a lot of pressure so what
you want to be able to do to reduce
overall use when possible is to know
where your thresholds are determine when
you have to might need to start spraying
preventatively and then monitor those
things to see if they're real issues so
i think it's really important for us to
use this as a baseline when is your
pressure low and avoid using the
products at that time now
spot treating another par strategically
applying pesticides only to areas under
high pressure to reduce pesticide use
and save money now this goes uh part and
parcel a little bit when pressure is low
so let's look at what the surveys uh
said here
basically
it looked like about 55 of the folks
were spot treating now when we look at
that a little more closely
we see it's equally dispersed right
equally dispersed
between the private and the public guys
now i'll draw your attention also to the
preventative pesticide answers
most of the private sector folks we
surveyed said preventatively and the
question was do you apply pesticides
preventatively to the majority of your
golf course uh majority of your treated
acreage and the private sector uh
currently you know certainly uh said
there they used it more preventatively
public a little bit down but still
almost 70 percent of the public mom and
pops are applying preventative
preventively but likely to putting
greens now spot treatment was 50 50. now
i think somewhat in the public sector uh
our discussion amongst carl and rick and
i is this might be weed centric
herbicide centric many people will spot
treat for weed control we want to
challenge you to think about this a
little bit more but let's start with the
par
first off why would you spray and try to
reduce your fairways first first
greens
generally on a per acre basis
consume the most pesticide risk right
because it's a lot of pesticides on a
small area but
fairway use has the largest cumulative
applications you're applying the most
materials to your fairways and carl uh
was involved carl and i were involved in
a scholarly publication that you can
find
that was peer-reviewed recently with our
colleagues in wisconsin and one of the
things that was really clear if you
apply to fairways less you're going to
save more money fairways are large areas
it's it's uh labor savings and also the
largest risk savings so if you can pay
attention to risk you can reduce it uh
by
you know
treating your putting surface right and
not worrying about the fairways as much
okay
so uh more about spot treating one of
the things is pretty common on annual
bluegrass weevil
is to just treat the perimeter
maybe you have some low-lying fairways
certainly like we've seen a lot this
past year with the rainfall where you
get a little bit more pithium on those
fairways than you do anywhere else but
again instead of looping every or
treating the entire fairway for abw
maybe you go to 12 acres
uh instead of treating all the pithium
you only go to the really wet spots
again there are micro
uh climates that you might get and this
is some work that's been going on in
wisconsin for a little while that paul
talks about the pathologist out there
where the ninth hole has lower dollar
spread pressure than the 18th hole so
they're able to make some decisions
based on pressure
maybe
based on your use this is from some uh
work we've done on the rtj golf course
here at cornell where we've gps tracked
golfers and see where they hit the ball
so maybe you might only treat your
landing areas where the majority of your
play is
and of course the classic way or the
high end way the eagle way
of reducing pesticide use by spot
treating is of course the adoption of
gps sprayers right now we've done a
little bit of work partnered with frost
incorporated from minnesota uh at skinny
atlas country club where the geometry
saved us 17
on the amount of product that we used
and when we put in labor costs the
return on investment was between uh what
was it was less than two years based on
product savings labor costs because of
the way they sprayed was a significant
reduction from what they were doing
previously so this is an eagle right we
don't expect everybody to go out and get
a gps sprayer but we might expect you to
be a little bit more careful about the
way you spray when you get out there now
let's talk a little bit about how spot
treating
that's a par
and scouting that's a birdie can go hand
in hand in reducing your pesticide use
first off you know the classic are you
using a check plot
how do you know if you needed to spray
if you don't have an area with disease
that you don't treat
you know i think this is one of those
things that unlike weeds where you spray
them and you see them die or you know
insects are a little bit like this you
spray you don't really know if you
needed it or not but with diseases in
particular it's really useful to have an
untreated control to look at and
understand what your pressure is so
that's a really good birdie here
now
less pounds on the ground ties in with
scouting it out how do we scout areas
spot treat to you put less pounds on the
ground well i'm gonna use our work that
carl and i have been working on with the
state park golf courses for a number of
years now where we look at the risk
associated with all their pest
management programs right and we've been
looking at it now for close to a decade
this is an example of some data from the
first seven years of the trial where we
were able to associate a significant
amount of the risk associated with all
of our pesticide risks with two pests
annual bluegrass weevil and dollar spot
in fact in 2014
almost 60 percent of all the risk
associated with our pest management
program was with annual bluegrass weevil
and dollar spot
and so we had embarked on a multiple
year
study trying to get
the golf course
the state park golf courses to
scout more and soap flush more and pay
attention to the population more and
choose products differently and target
those things differently because survey
data was showing we were spraying a lot
of insecticides now again pressure on
long island might be higher than it is
in western new york but i can tell you i
certainly know superintendents that deal
with annual bluegrass weevil this far
north
so so
with that as a backdrop
oops sorry
we were able to
promote scouting techniques put jugs of
soap in people's in the back of their
cart get people to actually write down
what they are doing and then look at
pesticide selection
and rotate those products to avoid
resistance manage resistance and reduce
overall pesticide use and and
and uh risk and what we found again this
is a birdie but for from this
perspective it's an example of a
scouting reducing the number of fairway
treatments by 39
over a seven year period
reducing the acreage by 23
and reducing the overall pesticide risk
by 65
so we are
choosing
less
risky products and we're using them at
lower and lower rates right so a nice
birdie is scouting spot treating and
choosing products that you can use at
lower rates all these things tie
together as a suite of practices
that can be a par a birdie or even in
the case of a gps sprayer all the way up
to an eagle as a way of reducing overall
pesticide use
targeting that pesticide where it's
needed and maintaining the same level of
efficacy with the products
now
predicting the risk that we've talked
about earlier we list as an eagle in our
suite of practices here i've already
talked about the smith kearns model
you're aware of the turf grass forecast
website that we have at our turf grass
cornell turf grass website
and it's our our model at the cornell
website is different than the smith
kearns model this is the one that's used
more commonly and it's just very good to
understand what this model is it
essentially is the environmental
conditions which are mostly temperature
and length of leaf wetness the longer it
stays wet
in the canopy
the more likely you are to have foliar
disease problems across the board i
don't care what they are when it's
really cool it could be micro dokie
patch when it's a little bit warmer it
could be dollar spot it gets a little
bit warmer it could be brown patch when
it gets really warm it can be pithier
blade or gray leaf spot right so when
you think about conditions that are
conducive for foliar diseases that's
what this model does it tells you yeah
based on temperature and amount of leaf
wetness you're going to start to get
dollar spot right around this point here
and then the dollar spot model shows
that the risk is increasing and then it
gets to a peak and starts to decrease
now what we've learned is as it starts
to decrease you could actually back off
spraying and in this case let's say we
did that our model says i don't really
have to worry for another five or six or
eight days at a 20 spray threshold if i
go up to 30 or 40 percent the whole idea
changes but what we're trying to
encourage here as a reach for an eagle
is to begin to use and look at these
models as ways of determining the way
you want to spray now do you have the
flexibility to go out and spray whenever
you want not likely so you do have
particular constraints around this do
you have the labor to go spray whenever
you can
you may not so using this risk even if
it's a way of narrowing the period of
time you have to treat is really
important to begin to start to adopt
and finally as i wrap up before we start
to take any questions i want to talk a
little bit about this wonderful resource
that we've developed that meets an eagle
but is relatively straightforward to do
and that is
having a written spill control procedure
in the case of an emergency we were very
surprised to see
the adoption of this particular uh
indicator for bmp so low it was actually
not common to see a spill drill
so
on the website you can go to
uh look at our checklist and it's
available to control contain
contact and get more information and
clean up the area so we have this little
checklist here that you can make into a
placard
and then have next to where you spray
so that if something happens you know
how to deal with it this is an eagle but
it honestly
it you know if car was playing it would
be a 480 yard par-5 it's a guaranteed
eagle uh for for our mid-am champion
carl scamenti so i want to believe this
is this can be a a getable eagle for
everybody uh listening today uh so i'll
remind you one more time
of the website that's available for you
to get more information about that and
hope whether you're watching live or
you're um
watching it recorded that you reach out
to us uh give us some feedback
we're always happy to hear from you and
let us know successes questions that you
have and i guess carl for me now
i will stop sharing and look at you
and say do we got any questions uh
clarifications or comments that either
you or rick want to make to color in
some of the lines here
yeah so i think i'll start with a
question frank while we're waiting for
some of our live audience to get theirs
in
um so say i'm watching this and i
haven't heard many of these bmp bmps
before like even if you're talking about
some of the pars like spot treating or
control plots
um so i see all these things and let's
say okay yeah
i'm kind of hearing these things i want
to do them
what's the first step should i try and
do all of these bmps all at once are
there should i should i kind of dip my
toe in the water what's the best process
for me if i'm hearing this
newly as a superintendent what's the
best process for me to start embarking
on this this kind of bmp journey
i would say the place to start thanks
for that question carl i would say the
place to start is to start my
my my opinion is to start monitoring
pressure really get a handle on the
kinds of pests that you're going to
struggle with
find areas that you're not going to
treat as intensely that are low stakes
areas areas that if you lose a little
bit it's not too bad you know maybe the
front end of a fairway it may be the
back of a tee like rick showed in that
great slide i would start and one of the
things that bugs me sometimes carl is we
don't even know because we spray
preventatively so much we don't honestly
know what the pressure is now that's not
fair either i go to places where like
you do at bethpage
the line of insecticide where grub
damage is right on where they you know
right on where the line is right and one
side where they don't treat so you have
problems that are endemic
and it's good to understand what they
are but not everything is like that so
what i think i would start with is
monitoring that pressure
and then i would simply take rick's
advice
and not do anything in the spring in
some of those areas and see what
happened
and i think what i've learned carl and
then i am starting here
is that when i worked with some guys in
cape cod that couldn't spray abruptly
had their pesticides taken away from
them abruptly one of the things that i
heard both my buddies there bruce and
chris
tell me was
hmm
i never didn't spray before and i think
i'm spraying more than i need to i
didn't think i could get away with this
and so i want to use that as a
sort of aha moment i think that's where
everybody needs to start because once
you start there carl you get in the
mindset and that's what i couldn't
really portray in the in the in the in
the laundry list of things that we're
trying to you know get in the record is
is there has to be a mindset and it
begins with i want to know what my
pressure is i want to know what kind of
grasses i want to grow and that's where
rick's been really beating the drum
don't spread don't grow grassy she got
to spray all the time unless you
absolutely positively have no other
choice number one number two
i think rick would also say you'd be
surprised how much grasses can adapt to
the things that we do not make it ugly
you know that forgotten tea an article
he wrote a long time ago but nobody's
noticing everybody forgot about it
nobody said oh look at how good this is
now so i i think it begins with
understanding the kind of pest pressures
that you have
understanding there are times when
that's greater or lesser depending on
the environmental conditions and then
strategically making decisions of the
way you want to intervene well let me
take a little more data and find out
what my abw pressure is let me let me uh
take a little more data and look at the
models and see is the line going up
going down or let me take some fufu dust
that's lower risk
right a fungicide that might be lower
risk and use that when pressure might be
a little bit lower right and then save
uh maybe other materials when pressure
might be higher depending on efficacy
that you get and safety there so
start with
bigger thresholds understanding your
pressure getting the right grass fixing
the site
making sure you got a place for the
grass to thrive that's why we started
there
i could keep going what do you think i i
think it's um so it's interesting i
always try and draw these analogies to
sports when we talk about
okay this coach decided to kick it on
fourth and two or went for it and fourth
and two and you never really know kind
of what it would have worked out to if
he had gone for it instead of kicking it
this to me is that situation where you
can know both things if you have a
little checkplot you can know hey if so
i sprayed everything except this thing
and okay it got diseased and and okay so
i should have sprayed and that's a good
communication tool to your membership
and
and to people who sign off on your
budgets okay i sprayed and here's what
it would have looked like if i didn't
spray now the flip side of that is i
sprayed and they don't look any
different okay that's more data and
that's stuff i can put into my system
and my analytics and the next time i've
got that fourth and two i can say you
know what last time i didn't need it
maybe this time i don't need it or i can
treat half a fair way here or half a
fair way there
um i really like that idea of that
approach it gives you more information
doing the same thing and you don't have
to risk job security right off the bat
by not spraying a whole fairway do a
little ten foot by ten foot area over
there and give you some data i think
it's cr critical that it's low stakes to
begin with and i think you know even
with the buffer zones right to that
point um you know we're really exploring
that rick talks a lot to us about that
it's like well i started out with a lot
and then you know you have to tweak it
with feedback and you know you do what
you can and then you make adjustments
and i think that's again it's the
mindset of i i know what i'm trying to
accomplish which is have more areas
around water bodies that i don't have to
treat because
that's a known risk situation
and so i well if you look at the picture
behind me you know sometimes those areas
are in play so you have to be really
thoughtful about the way you approach
this and so here's what i wouldn't do i
wouldn't stop spraying pesticides
completely i wouldn't start
i wouldn't stop mowing large areas of
the golf course where the greens
committee hits on a regular basis those
are big things i wouldn't do and again i
you know i would say there are places
where you can go a little cold turkey
and manage your risk and i think rick
talked about with water i think i would
use the same philosophy with um
with pesticides that there probably is
some damage and of course there is this
mentality it's one way of getting the
annual bluegrass the weaker species out
of there but it requires discipline carl
and it's not so easy so you have to be
able to discipline yourself and make
adjustments
yeah and the last thing i comment there
frank is you know we were seeing these
kind of public versus private
differences in some of the bmps and the
long grass around a certain area was one
of those where we saw it was harder for
private clubs to to do that and in a lot
of those cases it was because of the
greens committees and the architects
working with the golf courses wanting
the golf course to play a certain way
um i would say that using data like you
talked about the dive the preserve
six to eight people year round starting
to quantify that sort of thing hey it's
going to take x labor hours which
translates to x dollars to maintain that
clean look versus here's what i could do
and here's how i could reallocate that
labor not that you have to necessarily
argue with hey we should let it go long
grass but just presenting those two
options again using that data
as a communication tool
i think can be really powerful if you're
trying to get sort of closer to these
bmps yeah because one of the things that
we talk about regularly carl is the
adoption of these bmps
isn't something people honestly don't
want to do it's that there really isn't
anybody yelling about these things
except us and certainly among the people
who it's not on their radar is their
golfers
right this generally is not something
that's being pulled through
uh by the golfers so
um
i'd like us to make sure we're always
mindful of the way we communicate this
and the importance of doing it in in a
in a planned uh intentional way rather
than haphazard
yeah okay um so so i think no questions
frank other than uh asking what is in
your cup and uh
what's frank drinking during the webinar
is it's the one minute it's a cup of
coffee i wish it was something at this
time of day it's a cup of coffee later
today could be something different never
mind yeah the caffeine is
performance-enhancing
yeah with that frank we'll wrap it up
thanks to our live audience for for
being there i've put links in the chat
for our live audience i'll put those
under this youtube video so the things
that frank was talking about during the
presentation you'll have those links
right down there um thanks everyone for
joining uh we hope this was educational
for you created some awareness maybe
pushes you towards some of these bmps
that's uh what this project is all about
so thank you all for joining uh we'll
see you one more time for the pollution
prevention uh webinar where we'll have
rick slattery again with his practical
experience
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu